Chelsea wrote in saying have you guys
reconnected or remained in touch with
old classmates some of my closest
current friends are people that have
known since elementary school yeah so I
think that there's a group of people
from my third-grade classroom when we
were eight to nine years old that I'm
still in touch with people from middle
and high school absolutely now have I
reconnected with people that I had not
been connected with for a while yeah i
think when i moved to Boston actually I
have classmates more from like middle
and high schools in elementary school
who live here that after not being in
touch with for a while I reconnected
with but yeah I know a lot of people who
say they don't they don't keep in touch
with anybody they were friends with
prior to college or at most high school
but I'm still in touch with a lot of
people from elementary school yeah
that's good news I mean you grew up in
Northampton and while there is
definitely some some rising industries
there and plenty of opportunity I think
a lot of people move to the city after
they got out of college and given that
Boston's the closest city to where you
are from it makes perfect sense that
you'd be able to reconnect with them
there were actually even more people
from my elementary school living in New
York City when I live there although it
is farther from Northampton but you know
the draw of the really big city rather
than just kind of like a soon what would
you call Boston small to medium medium
the thing about Boston is like this the
city itself isn't doesn't have much
populations may got 600,000 people but
if you include the outskirts of the city
like Cambridge and the rest of the
suburbs I mean I think it's the tenth
largest metropolitan area in the club I
think the metro area is like close to
four million yeah it's either three and
a half or four and a half or four
million something like that yeah Boston
only has about six hundred and eighty
thousand people in any case now your
hometown is where you went to elementary
school is even closer to Boston then
where I went to elementary school so I'm
good right lots of people are around oh
yeah maybe an hour or so west and you
know my parents still live there so I'm
constantly in touched and I'm also just
not too far removed from high school in
college and easily the best friends that
I have and that I've maintained
relationships with our from those years
do you have people that you are friends
with now that you recognize your friends
with because of some kind of shared
history but if you met them now you
probably
wouldn't become friends either because
of politics or interest in life or
whatever because I a lot of friends
where I know that because we've been
friends since we were like eight nine
ten or eleven we're still friends but we
have absolutely nothing in common yeah
there's even one I can even think of now
where we'll hang out and we'll be like
why are we even friends we don't really
have that many shared interest yeah of
course like we're you know personable
enough to where we can kind of make
those jokes but let you don't have that
much in common ya know there's a number
of friends where it's very clear that
when they they are I try to mix friend
groups often and some of my friends
generally think that's a bad idea and
sometimes when someone from like
elementary school or middle school that
fits this description will join like a
group of newer friends that I've made
like since becoming you know more of an
adult and entering the profession I
don't like that at all it doesn't work
that well and it can create some awkward
situations yeah you know I don't really
I'm not averse to awkwardness but yeah
it's something that you know happens to
the best of us I think it's the best way
to say that's it for today we've got a
great bonus show coming up david
pakman.com slash membership coupon code
if you want it I voted 17 and of course
david pakman show coffee which I have
right here available at david pakman.com
slash gear we have both the espresso and
drift coffee blends we can send it to
you in whatever grind you want all the
way down to Turkish or just send it to
you with whole bean I personally grind
my own copy but to each their own I say
it with peace and love I thought you
were a turkish kind of guy now i do
espresso just turkish a little little
too fine for my taste although i love
turkish coffee had Turkish coffee the
other day I haven't even heard of it oh
I got to be honest I'm gonna ask you
better try well wants to talk about that
on the bonus show talk to you then